to be here is our first webinar and sir
our trial so you guys are the guinea
pigs and it's great to be the connect
with you guys I've done a lot of
workshops here and in my city and
presentations we have done webinars
before so it's not used to not seeing my
audience but I'm looking forward to
having a good discussion today so today
we're going to talk about getting past
revival and we're focusing in on the
early stage starting your business and
we're going to look at 12 rules for sort
of success today's part once we're going
to look at the the first six rules I
just wanted to go over a couple ground
rules so about me for those of you who
don't know me help entrepreneurs my
goals out the billion entrepreneurs when
I was 19 I had a 5-foot software company
built it up sold it and then was 22 i
joined the vc venture capitalist who are
raising half dome 250 million for
companies there's a bunch of
miscellaneous stats on me now my main
business is Emma chronicle com and our
goals to help a billion entrepreneurs
and 30 of them might have 32 32 so I
always have to think of what year it is
so a little bit about me after those of
you who aren't as simulator so the
biggest thing for a lot of entrepreneurs
when the first thing that is getting
past the survival stage and you may have
your huge visions of where you want to
go and you know the world you want to
change and that's awesome step one is
you got to get to survival you know if
you're not able to put enough money on
the table to to feed yourselves and pay
for your rent and everything else then
you're not gonna be able to have that
big vision for your business so this
part is really focusing on how can we
get to that survival point so you're
making up money to put your job and
start having the life that you want and
then you be able to make it big and
hopefully change the world a quick note
on questions ideally we're gonna have a
question intersection at the end but if
there's a really important question that
you have feel free to ask it and Carl's
wondering the the questions may
interrupt in in a sec question if it
really pertains to the topic work Achmed
on the slide then feel free to ask it
we also have a section at the end so
we're gonna get to the incubator
question and if you have other ones that
let me know two and one let's hang on
prizes we're going to do some prizes
here we're going to have one prize it's
gonna be a 30 minute call with me to ask
any question talk about your business
and we're also going to give away some
packs of the famous entrepreneur trading
cards that I created and that's going to
be awarded by questions and to be a
random question so make sure you're
asking those questions we're going to
pick one winner at random for the call
and a couple for the carts and Carl will
figure that out at the end of the call
so here we go the first six rule so
quick overview what we're going to talk
about today number one follow your
passion number two work to learn number
three star part time number four builder
on a customer number five income depends
on the value provide and number six is
mild success and you stick around other
with to the end I'm also going to
include a sample mentoring script I know
that's something that a lot of people
are worried about and thinking about how
do I get our mentor to help me with my
business and so I'm going to show you
how you can do it and give you an actual
script that you can use and copy and
paste you're going to start emailing
some potential message so I hope you're
excited I'm excited then let's pick this
thing on so first rule and by far the
most important rule at least in my
opinion when you're starting the
business is you have to do something
that you're super super passionate about
too many entrepreneurs start a business
just because trying to make money and
that's almost always the wrong way to
not do it you'll often find the people
who are just trying to make money really
end up making money exchanges that
sounds and you look at the most
successful entrepreneurs in the world
and you can do your own research we've
done a lot on our site you'll find that
they started a business because they had
a really strong passion for doing
something we want to change the way that
things were done and they were they
would do it even if they weren't making
money from it they couldn't turn it into
a full-time business they would still do
it and those are the ones who go on to
become hugely successful entrepreneurs
and so I want to encourage you if you're
at the point we were thinking about what
business you want to start to really
focus in on something that you're
passionate about because it's going to
be tough the entrepreneurship is sexy
and everybody wants to do it and be your
own boss and working
hours but it's really hard and you'll
every entrepreneur go to the point where
they think about quitting and going back
and getting the job because it's just
too hard and if you're not really
passionate about it you're going to give
up and so if you just chased into the
dollars it's finally not gonna happen
you know first sign of failure you're
gonna give up and go chase something
else where if you are going after
something you're really passionate about
and really fuels you you'll get that
energy to push through all the hurdles
that are going to come at you and it's
also a lot more fun when you're helping
people and you do something that excites
you it's way more fun and way more
profitable than just going out and I'm
trying to make a buck so I really want
you guys to think about how you can
connect to your passion and be able to
build a business around and I'm going to
go through a quick exercise of how to
help you identify what your passion is
and you'd then be able to build a
business from it so I just did a quick
google search yesterday and I put in how
many people hate and the top results
coming back where their jobs their life
their boss and their mother I don't
think I can help you much with your
mother if that's challenge but your job
your life your boss is probably
something that can help if you're going
to be an entrepreneur so a lot of people
hate what they're doing and that's what
forces people to start their own
business because they don't like their
current environment and so I want to
encourage you to do it and kind of give
you some of those steps to help you
through that process so a couple quotes
from famous entrepreneurs you don't
believe me then hopefully these guys
will help convince you as well and and
when I was getting started I found that
this was really helpful to be able to
look at famous entrepreneurs and see how
they were successful and that gave me
the inspiration and motivation to keep
going when things got really fast and
that's one of the main motivations that
i started my website so this from Dana
White who's the president of UFC rights
ninety percent of America gets up in the
morning values to a job they hate that's
true and as an entrepreneur you get the
chains to be able to create your own
destiny create your own work life and
choose projects to work on that that
excite you so hopefully if you're an
entrepreneur you're not going to a job
that you hate you're creating your own
life and something that you really have
a passion for doing
PA wouldn't appear Omidyar founder of
ebay but insane pursue your passion if
you're passionate about something and
you work hard you will be successful
again talk about that passion making
sure you're following it and use that to
be able to fuel your business growth and
one more Dov Charney founder of american
apparel passion that's it when you
believe in what you're doing that's it
and again if you look at any famous
entrepreneur their success story go back
to the beginning nobody will say I did
this because I wanted to make a lot of
money I did it because I really loved
what I was doing and I wanted to have an
impact on the world or impact on my
market and as a result that became
really successful you have to you have
to make money right you gotta you have
to make money if you're in business but
it's not the main goal your main goal is
a greater purpose and be able to create
something that you're really proud of
about what done so quick exercise on how
to find your passion get a lot of
questions on it I don't want to spend
too too much time on it but because they
can so many questions let it be helpful
to go to a quick exercise you're not
sure what your passion about or what
businesses start what I recommend doing
is write down a list of 10 things that
make you happy don't worry about it
being a business opportunity I just
things that you get a natural high off
doing you really enjoy super fun and
exciting to you and then think about how
much do you love it rank it out of 10
and how much does it help others so
that's the value so I want you to write
down here one to ten your activities how
much do you love it out of 10 and then
how much value does it give to other
people so the more that you're able to
help with the people the more you can
hope to make it into a business and
become successful then you add it up so
this last column is going to be your
total score and it's going to be out of
pointy so again you don't do worry about
it being a business opportunity yet just
start around what you're really excited
about and passionate about what makes
you happy what helps others and generate
that list and this is your starting
point the next thing I would do here is
right there on another list of up to 10
of what you wish you could do so you
know the world were limitless you know
which it pretty much is what what you
wish you could do ideally in an ideal
world you may not have too much
experience in it but you really have a
strong passion to learn about
something what type of opportunity could
you create and then do it again for what
kinds of frustrations have you solved a
lot of the best businesses in the world
has been created by entrepreneurs who
had our their own personal challenge of
frustration they wish something could be
different and then they created a
solution to it well if you're having
that problem chances are other people
are having that problem too and that's
how you could start a business so
ideally you have a list of maximum of 30
ideas of things that you like things
that you wish you could do and
frustrations that you've solved and
you've ranked them all by how much you
love doing those activities and then how
much value you think it provides to
other people what I want you to then do
is think about the ones that score
higher than 16 and circle them and those
are going to be our starting point for
business opportunities to be able to
build around what we're really
passionate about